unser andere spieler alter der haut mich
die ganze zeit die soll verläuft
vollkommen zu einer runde etwas zusammen
mit dem lieben verloren mit 3 2 1 los
geliebt hallo valuten die spielen eine
rolle wo es schon gesagt welcher
traumhaften app die mir was durch
botschafter oder ich bin da und ich bin
auch da hinten naja ich weiß gar nicht
wie eine echte ja ist für ist die sind
schon wirklich gut gebauten da vorne in
der mitte ist ein riesiger bei eur 6
grube kommt noch mal warum hier müsst
bluten immer wenn der ausland hatte auch
eigentlich mit kürbis auf seinen kopf
und deswegen heute mich manchmal nicht
so gut was machst du denn jetzt nach
oben bauen also ich dachte die frau ihr
sohn weg in den steinigen weg so der
kommt nicht rüber
also wir nehmen eigentlich eine folge
aufgrund von bludenz etwas woche für
woche und da reicht zu gast also kann
auch wenn ihr wollt beim unser andere
spieler alter der haut wie die ganze der
mine die soll
du weißt ja wenn man eine micro sd
zeichen geben möchte ja dass ich mich
mit ihm hoch bauen soll
und er schlägt mich jetzt die ganze zeit
und meinte ich so die blöcke dahin
setzen lassen und wir sterben glaube ich
dass das gold ja ich hab viel gold
tatsächlich gesagt okay an wird jetzt
ich bin jetzt wieder zu hause also wir
haben auf paten kanal eine runde
bergbaus aufgenommen und es war auf
jeden fall sehr sehr adrenalin geladen
und erotisch es gab es gab alles erotik
gutes gameplay und hatten blaue hallo
hier gab es nicht es war ein
alkoholisches irgendwas gibt es auf
meinem kanal ist eigentlich ohne
alkoholische und alkoholfreien gibt es
das wort und alkoholisch ich glaub nicht
oder immer alkoholisch das klingt auch
einfach folgerichtig schon wieder tut
mir letztens mal diesmal berechtigt
direkt niemals das nicht berechtigt
aldiana das war das war dann schon
wirklich sehr kleinlich aber wir
schreiben sondern muss mal ich kann mich
daran erinnern
naja kommt auch immer darauf wert
eigentlich schon eingebaut
nein ich glaube ich noch nicht getan wie
es ist aber glaube ich das ist das ist
eine aufgabe für dich dass er ihr müsst
es in der runde vorher hatte ich so
viele kills so viel hatte ich noch nie
meiner ganzen bett wars karriere
das ist echt also der letzten runde bin
ich echt auch nicht abgegangen hab ich
so einiges gilt am tag gepackt wo ich
nicht wusste dass sie überhaupt bei mir
irgendwo im tiefsten innern stürmern das
war eine dieser dieser 360 loskill war
war schon ziemlich sec könnte aber nur
genannt seinem video sehen sonst nicht
mehr gestellt weiß nicht das ist zwecks
also dabei musik stehen die wollten
nämlich wichtig die schweben so direkt
über mir in welchen sinn text zu lernen
es 632 wechseln oder 64
ich glaube 100 100 100 tausend wie
weltliche das ist mein schnetzeln jetzt
ich hab nämlich hier eine rede
spitzhacke stille nacht mit schnitzel
mainz zu kämpfen
netzel würdig kraft blöcke aufbauen weil
ich absolute spitze
ein schwert ich habe mich doch die reise
soll aber ich gehe mal insel mittel
naja ich finde ich meinen stock einfach
und boxkämpfen sind team blau ja selber
laufen kommen mit erich so gehen witzig
es auch okay jetzt auch mit den wolken
anders gar nicht dem grünes team gelten
dann habe ich eine gelbe eine ist
einfach unter gefahr ist jetzt zug hat
laut in osnabrück jetzt mit magix legt
los los los los nennen wir ihn mal
zickig gehst du zu werke positiv ist
doch nur eins tik tok ich gehe einfach
selber was sag ich halt den auf
abenteuer ich bin tot aber ich glaube du
musstest bis nach oben gekommen um sich
haben dass du das heißt sehr sehr gut
gemacht
sehr sehr gut du hast dein leben für
mich geopfert und jetzt kriegen wir den
einher
das war eine richtig starke technik
ehrlich bist du fertig bist du so gemein
zu rüstung und dann machen wir das
gleiche noch mal bei den anderen spielt
sich bitterböse 22 krieges gibson nicht
derart gelbe blumen lange nicht ich
mache jetzt erstmal wir haben ich gar
kein eisen doch das hat noch nicht
gespart
ich muss ich muss kurz zum team geld
zurück war auch waren da steht das
wissen ich komme weil dann fühlst du
dich vielleicht sicherer bot den habe
ich nicht getroffen oder wirklich
schnitzel oder auch nicht okay du bist
chris hey wieso kann ich dir nicht
treffen was denn da los ja jetzt müssen
wir jetzt müssen wir zugriff auf die
mittel weil ja wir haben sich dahin
gelaufen
damit ist ein roter
ein problem sind den kriegs- oder den
krieg ich dachte nur weil du mal ist
dass du damit möchte ich wollte in die
mitte zurück gelaufen weil da 2 lotte
kam das war ein bisschen ein bisschen
too much
ich weiß nicht ob ich den krieger das
schafft jetzt am besten habe ich
natürlich nie gedacht du musst an dich
glauben
aber das war so ehrt mich zuerst
getroffen der so stark ist
ich möchte man zudem da hinten
du musst einfach wenn immer nur
aufpassen nicht dass ich da ein risiko
ins netz in dem man nicht einfach mit
magic stick oder so ja da war gerade von
jungen jetzt treffen sich gerade welche
farbe sind wir wir sind blau
wir sind ok dann helfe ich mal den
blauen sind auch einer weniger als ein
paradies
der hatte nur noch halb ist herz oder so
ich habe die kunden der mich töten ist
andré mit demenz kommt sind machen wir
das hätten alle ist alles geschafft in
einem letzten leben also gerade ich habe
leider nur ich hab dein tod gerecht der
war allerdings nur weil der hat echt
nichts mehr
und dann habe ich noch einen anderen
getötet aber dann kam somit zum bogen
und der war tödlich also wert setzt
damit die zeigt wo der frosch die locken
ich verstehe diesen spruch ich lag das
ganze auf wo der frosch die locken hat
aber ich weiß ich hab ich das gerne
gehört eine echte wo der frosch die
locken hat ja ihr habe ich weil ich mich
mit ihm gesprochen also da gibt es ja
gar keine socken beim branchen er meine
meine wolken machen die welt so
unsichtbar bisschen kennst du die sind
nicht weiß die machen das ganze
irgendwie durchsichtig die welt
warte da von rechts kommt wird ein ok
den druck effektiver den bogen weiter
weil ich habe mir betroffen
das ist nicht wahr wie oft muss ich mich
dann aus gerüsten hier
deshalb gibt's auch die famose strategie
sich einfach gemacht
jetzt glaube ich aber hat er mit dem
team gegen einen bogen mit danke ich
weiß ja dass so was auch das ist wir
haben gesehen wie du zweimal geboxt hat
ja erst mal gucken abschicken
ihr müsst wissen ich noch in der runde
die wir bei minuten gespielt habe habe
ich mich so hoch geworden mit den
blöcken und dann hab ich gesehen hat
mich mit zum teil und bogen ab
schließlich das schiff nicht immer ab
und verlud und ich habe währenddessen
unterhaltung wurden dann beide ein
bisschen ruhiger aber wert weil der
kampf situation waren und er sowieso
treffe ich ihn nicht ich sogar um mich
ist eine befreiung bogen ja so wird das
mal das war auf jeden fall keine
sternstunde
wir sind ja auch nur menschen
roboter du bist eigentlich auch ein
kürbiskopf abgelegten boden drin ja den
habe ich noch keine zeit gehabt doch
gesagt ich auf den boden
das nicht ein bisschen spalt gepasst und
glaub ich sage da müssen aufpassen nicht
als ob ich da kein treffer oder es war
sogar ein blauer von uns der dritte im
bunde
ich kriege grüne grüne libelle diese
sind wir nicht viel
ich habe er war weil die leute als er
eine aus unserem thema gesagt
ganz ehrlich nein da gibt es immer wir
waren auch wohin nur zu zweit aber haben
es gewonnen
da werden sie von blau lasst uns den
chinesen von der seite ab sagt jetzt
unten jetzt da du gehört zugriff ok go
go go jetzt ist aber keiner bei uns
gerade bitte keiner ist bei uns ja jolo
es ist echt ein bisschen blöd mit diesen
worten es ist schon interessant egal
durchlaufen alle durch richtig ich hau
dir da hinweg kein okay hatten
aber jetzt geht's sofort zurück sofort
zurück nennt jahren evtl
ich gebe zu enstone killers tod der
einfachheit abbekommt jetzt ist sie
wieder weg
oh gott das noch ein assist lag bei mir
mega beim jetzt auch ein bisschen gelegt
nicht komplett ja das ist das war völlig
völlig korrupt konnte übertreffen aber
ich bin jetzt in unserer base schaffst
du dir ja ich glaube alle großhandel
sind welche von roten ja die skis mich
gefallen habe aber ich denke eigentlich
dass das schaffen müsste ich komme
einfach so in die mitte wo sich aber ich
habe einfach dem bett geholt fahrt ok
saubermann verdammt wo bist du bei uns
gucken die angst irgendwie kriege aber
ich hab dir echt gut gehütet wird mich
denn dann noch wie viel hält der denn
aus ist schon oder oder legt der ich bin
ich habe nicht für uns schwer werden
jetzt auch wieder nur eins holen müssen
halt gucken dass wir dürfen einfach
nicht so sehr die mitte verlieren dass
wir da ja sozusagen kein gold mehr
bekommen dass die dann alle bögen haben
weil dann wird es wirklich wirklich
schwer
das auch gemein wenn die alles für sich
nehmen finde ich das ist das ist
wirklich das zerbricht mir oder zerreißt
mir auch manchmal mich das herz so ist
hier nicht verteilen können sie komplett
egoistisch mach ich jetzt habe ich keine
blöcke dabei gucken
das sind auch werden so witzig wenn
jetzt rüber kommen würden und uns was
geben würden
ok ich hab' ein gekillt sauber okay ein
mit dem eisenstädter die sind jetzt aber
richtig
ich muss jetzt einmal ganz schnell in
mittel damit ich ein mal gold holen kann
der andere aber ich muss sagen respekt
an
wie heißt der zusammenbau schlafen da
glaube ich oder mein leben ich mich na
du schlägst sich das glas noch selber
gut ja das ist richtig ich habe mich
immer selbst runter server wo sich nach
jamaika
das habe ich doch die sind richtig in
bari kripo sicht warte ich lauf hinter
dem her und den einkriegen id laufe auch
nicht raus erwarte einfach nur schwer
tue ja einer von rotos hinter mir aber
ich glaube ich weiß nicht ob ich dann
runter boxen soll also versuche liebe
dich lieber ein bisschen zu entfernen
weil lok bist du gerade über die brücke
läuft ja aber unser team at kommt da der
smag den wenn ich den jetzt noch helfen
nein es kommt comcom du musst ich kriege
ja fünf gold für ein schwert ich hab nur
vier habe ich keinen bogen machen ich
kann den bogen machen
okay sagt den einen habe ich gedacht
okay ich habe jetzt noch einer über
reisen schwert und bogen
aber der hatte keine rüstung sauber auch
gds dauern ich habe jetzt ein bogen
gemacht ich komme jetzt auch mal wieder
rüber ich habe wahrscheinlich wieder
überfalle oder so aber die sind jetzt
aber schon wieder in der mitte ehrlich
da bist du aber er wird mich natürlich
habe leider keine rüstung
ich versuche den einen von rot mehr zu
nehmen es ist ruckelt immer so
kurzfristig oder der typ bleibt einfach
stehen weil sie nicht nenne das ich
glaube die großen pharao dass er
versucht einer einer von rot zu uns
rüber zu kommen kannst ihn abschießen
ich denke ich auch so er ist aber den
habe ich heute bin ich gott beschäftigt
mit den anderen beiden roten da sind
zwei roten damit ich glaub wenn wir die
beiden weltkriegen würden dann wird es
auf jeden fall schon mal besser gehen
nahm ist der eine hat mich genutzt der
kann aber auch nicht mehr viel haben
da ist ein anderer den habe ich jetzt
vier mal gerettet fünf mal darüber
doch was haben die denn für kranke sie
haben ein gast tot okay der anderen oft
drüber ich weiß nicht wer der stoppte
mal so kurz setzt ganz raffiniert aber
ich glaube jetzt können wir über gehen
weil ich habe nur einen weg den können
wir den jacken quasi abschneiden ok also
nochmal angriff die sind halt trotzdem
zu viert naja das ist aber wie kriegen
wir kriegen sagt er einem irrtum
gespielt sind okay die haben alle ganz
krasse sachen ich weiß ich habe den
bogen haben wenden natürlich auch der
einen bogen
okay der einheit aber der wir bauen uns
gewandt
die ist sehr cool die wand kommen damit
darüber jetzt nicht wer ich habe mich
immer noch einmal kippen gute scores
eine zeit bin aber sofort da ich wohl
noch ein bisschen was zu essen gibt auch
wir sehen probieren die reise bisher
zustande in anderthalb herzen anderthalb
herzen aller herzen
ich laufe da zurück okay die treffen war
gerade nicht aber ich habe kontakt und
hat eine menge gold aber nur ein
halbherziges jetzt nicht mal hier
ablösen
die combat allem über rock liners runter
bisky nichts kommt dagegen halbes
herzlich lacht nein nein hätte mich
passt ja was ich da vielleicht ist dies
ja ich hab heute getötet ja ich sehe
dich da versuche ich hab's überlebt
gott kann uns jetzt aber schon wieder in
der mitte ich habe am ende musste ich
das wohl überleben ich werde das nicht
überleben
ich hoffe ich auf kuba zu den anderen
ein ich versuche irgendwie hinzukriegen
sagt wenn ich mich jetzt natürlich
abschieds mich am arsch dann sagt er
kommt auch an ein kleiner schlawiner
rüber
würde es halt ein bisserl ich hätte acht
gold wir waren so nah bei dem vor der
base aber die haben einfach da so viele
sachen gebunkert boss lakis ist nun
stock und brachte ist doch bitte mal da
sind
das ist einfach so geblieben hätte ich
es auf der überholspur weil sie es
einfach begraben sein land machen werde
ware die pauke hauen wir werden uns
jetzt beide wir brauchen einfach den
bogen er ohne bogen läuft nichts wir
müssen einmal in fahrt
die sag ich dir nicht behalten können so
ich so heimat und snack vier gold dann
haben wir ein bogen der müsste
eigentlich ausreichen
ja der reicht eigentlich dafür dass man
hier zumindest so ein bisschen ab werden
kann weiß genau einfach nur ein bisschen
zu zurückdrängen oder eine von uns
natürlich eine spitzhacke dabei aber so
wie ich das in geradezu ein paar sachen
von denk ich krieg proxy ich mache mir
jetzt noch eben ich will mir was für s
und jetzt gehe ich da einfach hin
ich packe michael rutter gelaufen
also ganz ehrlich wir unter geschubst
oder so leid aber das kann nicht sein
jetzt spielen wir zu zweit gegen ja was
vorher auch er das ist so ekelhaft dass
sie einfach alle lieben
der läuft jetzt nicht zu uns kommt da
nicht so schnell kann es daher egal ich
gehen die mitte wo du mir mal das gold
ist nicht so dass gold ich kümmere mich
um den ok ja damals lassen ruhig laufen
obwohl es einfach das gold ich werde
meinen weg weg bauen genau machen
bogenbau einmal den weg ab
ok ich laufe da drüber
der andere ist gerade bei der bei der
anderen partei der anrede an aber wo
bist du denn gerade ich bin immer noch
in der mitte ich baue jetzt gerade die
beiden wege ab damit sie dann wenigstens
noch ein bisschen sind zeit verplempern
müssen kirchhatten bogen ich kann dir
bringe neben einer von roth kommt
leuchten bitte sag ich ich werde mich
auch mag ich muss mich jetzt auch mal
zurückziehen obwohl ich warte noch ein
thema das kann selbst nicht mehr
einreisen schwertsik dem ellbogen ok
oder gehen vorüber
ich hab' ich bin super los die sind aber
die haben nichts da ich weder zwei
leuten die an beide nichts der andere
rote ist da hinten da sind zwei auf der
anderen seite die beiden roten wir
könnten so gut rüber da sind nur zwei ja
ich kann ich habe ja okay dann los weil
ich habe absolut nichts
also ich hab auch 300 herzen ich kann's
kaum zu wort
du hast ein bogen ihr ja aber eben keine
keine nahkampfwaffe die haben auch bogen
vom so opfer kalter dann lässt er sich
für eine typ auch noch von uns man jetzt
kommen sie aber auch oben snapped da ist
kommt irgendwie zu helfen
okay ich habe ein paar mal getroffen
aber gegen zwei hervor allerdings sind
die einfach komplett ja das
das können wir aufgeben wir sind nicht
aufgeben wir werden nicht aufgeben wir
werden das schaffen
aber das kann nicht sein
es kann doch nicht sein dass jemand von
uns dass zwei leute von uns letzten
einfach
das ist doch so bitter das macht
teilweise auf weiteres relativ kaputt
hört doch auf eine party genau die bauen
sie jetzt einmal nach oben
vor allem das ist so richtig um sie
nicht weil meine wolken dadurch kann ich
einfach nicht gesehen wie schnell wir
brauchen planten die einfach mehr
kriegen das hin und schmerz
ok jetzt kommt die ruhige phase euro der
ein konto zu gott
da hat er mich genutzt
ich boxe ich einfach kaputt
okay dass der eines der unten geht sind
sie jetzt sind sie alle im alter von nur
vier leute annehmen das ist das ende
kommen wie springen muss springt alles
was freunde es war eine aufregende
partie aber ich das nicht mehr machen
ich wette wenn wir zu viert gewesen wäre
hätten wir locker hin gekriegt aber über
ein solches fall egal luton ob die runde
bei piloten besser ausgegangen ist könnt
ihr auf dem kanal von piloten sehen bei
seiner bett wars woche tag 22 22 22 oder
23 12 und 22 tage hat die woche ja das
ist übrigens die neue wochen rechnung
die wochen haben jetzt neuerdings 21
tage und wenn ihr euch dann wenn euch
das anschauen möchtet könnt ihr einfach
auf den kanal gehen den hier unten in
der beschreibung seht wenn es euch
gefallen hat würde ich mich über einen
dampfen nach oben freuen und dann sehen
wir uns in einem nächsten video wieder